[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors je vais vous parler de
d'aménagement de territoire en matière
de sport alors je sais pas s'il y avait
beaucoup de sportifs dans la salle mais
peut-être que ça va parler à certains
moi je travaille depuis longtemps à la
fédération française de cyclisme pour le
sport de haut niveau mais j'ai d'autres
sujets et celui là me tient
particulièrement à coeur pour pouvoir
justement amenée la discipline vtt à un
grand public alors je vais développer un
petit peu le sujet pour justement que
vous compreniez un peu la philosophie de
ce projet
c'est comme à l'instar des murs
d'escaladé ou ou maintenant on a vu
aussi des stade d'eaux vives au niveau
du kayak s'est amené le sport plus près
de la ville pour qu'ils soient plus près
des utilisateurs potentiels
donc jusqu'à présent donc ce projet
s'appelle stade de l'été était jusqu'à
présent la fédération française de
cyclisme avait des sites vtt qui se sont
développées depuis maintenant une
trentaine d'années donc ça fait quand
même c'est un sport jeune mais c'est
aussi quand même étudié depuis un
certain temps on s'appuie à la
fédération sur tout ce qui est les
ventes de vélos encore aujourd'hui et
qui sont en développement surtout au
niveau du vélo à assistance électrique
vous pouvez voir qu'il ya quand même pas
mal de vélos vendus chaque année pour un
chiffre d'affaires qui est important et
les vélos à assistance électrique sont
aussi représente à peu près 10% et sont
surtout en fort développement à l'heure
actuelle au niveau des ventes
donc c'est ça qui nous intéresse parce
que en fait ce qui se passe c'est que
cette discipline parce que le vélo à
assistance électrique effectivement vous
allez me dire c'est plutôt en ville pour
le déplacement
oui c'est un c'est un véhicule d'avenir
mais on peut aussi le développer au
niveau loisir ça peut être un véhicule
polyvalent qui peut faire aussi bien le
déplacement urbain et si on a des stades
pas trop loin de la ville aussi prendre
du plaisir à piloter et à faire
une activité qui détend et qui fait du
bien à la santé vélos à assistance
électrique
on force beaucoup moins c'est c'est très
intéressant donc le jusqu'à jusqu'à
présent les sites vtt de la fédération
française de cyclisme et se basait sur
un développement qui était plutôt celui
des clubs dé ce territoire où on avait
des chemins on allait on partait faire
20 km en pleine nature
et puis des fois qu'on retrouvait pas de
panneau ben on se promet quoi donc c'est
vrai que c'était il y avait un
développement intéressant mais aussi
liées à l'entretien et aux gens qui
participaient dans les clubs à mettre en
place ces sites
donc pour répondre bon il y avait 1 on
veut dire la problématique du stade de
vtt pour répondre à cette petite info
qui avait conceptuel c'est aussi qu' il
ya des conflits d'usagé
vous avez peut-être entendu récemment
qu' un vététiste qui s'est fait tirer
dessus par un chasseur malheureusement
il est mort et c'est vrai que par le
chasseur le vététiste et donc c'est vrai
que ça pose des problèmes
il y avait déjà aussi les problèmes de
marcheurs de randonneurs et la vitesse
du vtt qui arrivent les chevaux et
éventuellement aussi utilisent les mêmes
circule donc l'idée de stade de vtt
c'est pour répondre à cette
problématique là donc de trouver des
terrains qui sont plus adaptées plus
restera en territoire est proche de la
ville c'était un peu les contraintes
on a des exemples depuis moi je voyage
beaucoup j'avais pas mal voyagé par
rapport à la discipline et c'est vrai
que en nouvelle zélande il ya plus d'une
dizaine d'années j'avais déjà vu un
concept que vous pouvez voir là sur la
carte
c'est un territoire il ya plus de 250 km
deux circuits l'un met ici là dans cette
zone là vous avez un petit parking qui
accueille les gens et nous l'a connu au
départ où il y avait il y avait rien le
gars qui venait avec sa remorque ces
vélos à louer et puis
dix ans après là il ya un petit chalet
de restauration il ya un loueur de vtt
un petit un petit magasin et autour de
la dans ce petit territoire là il ya
moyen déjà de passer un grand moment de
pratique on va dire après ça dépend du
temps qu'on a c'est ce concept là qui
est intéressant donc une petite vidéo
pour vous montrer le l'idée du projet
c'est une vidéo qui a été fait par les
dents pays de galles sur un site qui est
aidé par le développement de la de la
forêt là bas et ils font des
aménagements donc le mieux c'est de
regarder la vidéo tranquillement et de
voir un petit peu que on peut avoir un
magasin avec un concept de location de
restauration tout un panel de services
et à côté de ça ben des sentiers on part
on se retrouve entre copains entre entre
midi et deux pour ceux qui pourraient
avoir un peu de temps pour refaire de
l'activité sportive et donc partir sur
des sentiers alors ces sentiers sont
justement vous allez me dire ouais mais
c'est le vtt c'est très sportif là ils
sont un peu sale mais bon là c'est
l'angleterre alors c'est normal sont il
pleut souvent voilà ont cédé des
parcours qui sont quand même aménagé
avec des matériaux qui sont moins celle
quoi en dire ou c'est pas que de la boue
donc on peut profiter quand même 2 de
terrain
praticable un peu en tout temps et
surtout aménagé au niveau lui dit que
plaisir de pilotage c'est ce qui est
important c'est l'essence même de ce
sport c'est de se faire plaisir en
faisant du vélo c'est un peu comme quand
on monte sur une paire de skis bas après
on a envie de jouer avec les skis et et
voilà donc ce concept là même si là dans
les images que vous voyez ils sont assez
on va dire facile quoi les terrains ont
l'air facile après on peut imaginer
d'autres choses et d'autres concepts
mais la base c'est quand même d'avoir
quelque chose d'accessible et de des
parcours qu'ils soient roulable toute
l'année quoi les genres entre boire un
coup donc on peut les quitter voilà donc
le principe général de traçage de
parcours quand on est dans une forêt
généralement le sentier piéton il va
tout droit
ils proposent pas forcément des choses
très intéressantes si c'est sur du plat
donc imaginé un parcours ludique et
utiliser le terrain paysager à rendre
intéressant la pratique du vélo et
éventuellement partager l'espace parce
que du coup les piétons faire des tours
dé retourner sur leurs pas tourner
autour d'un arbre ça va vite les gonfler
donc et il serait seront sur les
sentiers les chevaux c'est à peu près
pareil aussi je pense mais par contre le
vélo on aura plus de plaisir à jouer
dans des terrains comme ça quelques
exemples d'aménagements qui peuvent
servir alors c'est ça c'est des images
qui ont été faites aux jeux olympiques
donc c'est pas c'est pour vous montrer
que maintenant aussi la discipline qui
est olympique le vtt cross-country
utilisent des stades
ils font
des espaces plus intéressant pour suivre
l'événement donc vous avez des
aménagements tout ça c'est des éléments
apportés donc ça peut servir pour une
compétition mais aussi ça peut des
aménagements loisirs plus free ride on
va dire voilà il ya moyen de faire plein
de choses sur la base du de l'espace on
peut tout à fait concevoir ce qu'on
appelle maintenant là les pommes traque
qui sont des petits outils y on va dire
pédagogique et d'entraînement pour
piloter le vélo comme ça alors
maintenant on ne les voit fleurir en
goudron d'aller me dire pour le vtt
c'est pas forcément intéressant non ce
qui est intéressant c'est que vous avez
aussi une pratique qui est possible avec
d'autres choses que le qu'un vélo comme
les trottinettes voit plein de jeunes
pratiquer ou skate même on voit plein de
jeunes pratiqués sur ces bases là donc
on peut voir sur l'image
ici vous avez des terrains de tennis à
côté donc ça peut on peut y greffer un
départ voilà il ça peut être le centre
névralgique du projet est donc amené un
petit peu plus de jeu j'ai pris un
exemple d'aménagement de territoire
c'est mon rêve donc je vais vous le
faire partager
il ya des zones qui sont potentiellement
intéressante que j'ai mise en verre là
vous avez on va s'intéresser à la
troisième pour prendre un exemple
d'aménagement quoi ça peut ressembler
fait un zoom encore on a donc une route
qui nourrit tout chemin forestier qui
traverse la forêt avec plein de petits
sentiers partout et ben ça quand on se
promène dans ce terrain en vélo
ben des fois on rencontre plein de gens
et c'est compliqué on prudent mais le
fait de sueur fréquenter des zones peut
amener un conflit d'usagé j'en ai parlé
tout à l'heure
donc l'idée c'est de faire c'est ce
projet sur un petit territoire pour
concentrer l'activité à zoom sur ce
petit territoire donc là en l'occurrence
si on prend cet exemple là vous
retrouver le tennis le petit chalet qui
pourrait être ici est une zone
accessible avec les les chemins
forestiers
donc on pourrait concevoir des petites
boucles de parcours de niveau vert pour
tourner autour du départ du point de
départ qui serait facilement réalisables
par les petits même maintenant fait
beaucoup pour les enfants la fédération
a commencé à développer des licences et
des cours pour les petits andrésienne
parce que c'est intéressant d'apprendre
à faire du vélo à ces jeunes et voilà
donc c'est ça pourrait aussi se réaliser
avec les tout petits vélos pour des
enfants en bas âge ensuite dessus on
peut greffer des petits parcours bleu
qui était un peu le parcours vert quand
les gens se sentiront un peu à l'aise de
pouvoir aller faire autre chose pareille
on continue on développe
le réseau pourra aller jusqu'à
éventuellement faire des zones au niveau
de plus technique qui se grefferait sur
le parcours donc tout ça pourrait faire
un incident de compétition après
éventuellement aussi parce que on a
ministère des sports qui a le même le
gouvernement l'a maintenant qui a choisi
de que paris sera candidat pour 2024
donc ça fait partie des projets il y
aura un stade de vtt dont le projet il
est là sur six c'est sur ce territoire
là c'est le projet de paris 2024 donc
vous voyez qui est aussi conçu pour être
mis en prêt à la disposition de
personnes
donc c'est pas c'est pas qu'un projet
compétition parce que la fédération tout
de suite aurait peut-être la connotation
de vouloir faire du sport de haut niveau
il ya vraiment des projets de
développement et d'accessibilité à la
pratique
vélo donc ces projets là on en a pas
encore qui sont réalisés vraiment on va
dire cd des échantillons dans certains
téléphones mais on n'a pas vraiment
projet concret et c'est vraiment tout
l'enjeu qu'on a la plaquette qu'elle
vient de sortir et c'est vrai que c'est
pour aider les les porteurs de projets
dans les régions ou les villes pour
avoir toutes ces infos et comment on
peut développer cette activité là ouais
je vous remercie de votre accueil
bonne soirée
[Musique]